the National Park Service held a meeting
earlier today to talk about managing
boat ramps as low water levels forced
the park service to restrict access over
the summer yeah they're expecting water
levels to drop another 20 to 30 feet
this year Mary Jane belly as a sharing
the concerns directly from boaters
more than 300 people gathered in Boulder
City to hear about the Lake Mead
sustainable low water access plant but
those I spoke would say they left with
more questions than answers the National
Park Service is initiating a plan to
address the low water levels at Lake
Mead by introducing three management
Concepts which would impact boat launch
ramps at five locations aside from
closing the marinas the National Park
Service would also close concessions cut
out utilities and move marinas to
another location Boulder City resident
Vicki Arnold says this move would
significantly cut down Recreation time
and alter the community's lifestyle
you're out there and you've got the land
and the water in the sky and it's just
an awesome place and time to be so but
so there's there's fear here of taking
our national Recreation Area away from
the people of the nation Margo alaire of
Las Vegas has been docking her boat out
at Lake Mead since 2005. she says the
public forum remains vague but let's
address the real issue which is the loss
of water and let's figure out better
ways to conserve it rather than
something like this I agree with Vicki I
think the agenda has already been
decided and this is just an attempt to
get people to supposedly a forum to
express their views I don't think it's
going to make any difference in Boulder
City Mary June bellezza 8 News Now